lemon water is a SLE I love lemon water
it's alkalinizing alkalizing alkalizing
it's very good for the body good to
flush out great to drink first thing in
the morning first of all while lemon
water does provide a bit of vitamin C
probably around 12% of the recommended
intake from the juice of half a lemon
nothing we eat or drink can alkalize our
blood or change our body pH the pH of
our body is actually very tightly
regulated period explanation point the
end this popular Wellness culture
concept is somewhat grounded in the fact
that lemon is technically an acidic food
but it increases alkaline byproducts
once it's metabolized in the body but
that just means it creates alkaline PE
not alkaline blood not an alkaline body
it changes our literal waste product
because we do not need it otherwise H so
if you like the flavor of lemon water
amazing drink up but it's not a magic
morning tonic and third doesn't flush
out your body AKA detox first thing in
the morning sure but so does literally
any form of hydration all water is good
water especially in the morning when
you've gone a whole night without
anything so yeah lemon lime bubbly
Infuse whatever all water is a sleigh in
my books